ou lortie vous avez commencé à jouer à
l'âge de 7 ans est rapidement vous êtes
devenue vertueuse
avec le recul avec toute l'expérience
comment vous expliquez tout ça hein dont
l'oreille absolue
certainement un don certainement un
besoin probablement de communiquer d'une
autre façon qu'avec la parole dans mon
cas il ya aussi un peu de mystère parce
qu'il ya une espèce de connexion
génétique parce qu'en fait c'est ma
grand mère que j'ai vu la première jouer
du piano une chose qu'elle avait
d'ailleurs pas fait depuis des années
j'ai senti quelque chose de spécial dans
ses relations avec le piano alors il ya
peut-être une espèce de transfert aussi
au niveau émotif
ce que j'ai découvert j'avais une autre
grand mec j'ai pas vraiment connu qui
était aussi pianiste donc c'est très
très très mystérieux qu'est ce qu'y
génétique et ce qui est peut-être ça
devrait le rester aussi mystérieux comme
comme la musique comme l'art en général
quand même choisi steria
mais en écoutant la le premier concerto
de mendelssohn comme doivent enregistrer
sous étiquette atma jeu va se poser la
question suivante comment faites-vous
pour mémoriser toutes ces partitions des
fois ça devienne le mieux c'est quand ça
vient naturellement c'est à dire que à
force de lire un peu comme un acteur
d'une pièce l'allier ali puis un moment
donné ça y est ça coule de source c'est
ça qui était préférable
par exemple quand on a un long voyage à
faire en avion en train on puisse
imaginer par exemple en train de jouer
la pièce avec les doigtés tout ça et
quand ça c'est très très clair dans la
tête en fait on est beaucoup moins
nerveux après sur scène le fait de
l'avoir intérieur
tout un exercice vraiment extraordinaire
où on dit d'ailleurs qu'on fait à
prendre souvent aux gens la musique
justement pour prévenir les problèmes de
démence ou d'alzheimer
parce que c'est une activité cognitive
qui est vraiment extraordinaire je me
rends compte évidemment en vieillissant
c'est moins facile que quand on est très
jeune mais c'est un exercice je le sens
qui régénère je suis pas scientifique
mais les cellules on sent que c'est
quelque chose qui travaillent qui seront
bons à faire travailler
vous le sentez on le sent absolument on
ne sait encore quand je mangeais pas
mémoriser de nouvelles choses depuis
longtemps je sens que ça commençait à
brouiller un peu c'est un exercice aussi
et il ya des compositeurs évidemment qui
sont plus complexes que dorothée ce
niveau là pour la mémoire
vous avez déjà dit que le métier
d'instrumentistes et dur pour le corps
que c'était un tabou dans l'industrie
vous le devez encore ça c'est mou relié
à votre métier à cette façon de jouer
mais je crois que c'est dans plusieurs
milieux c'est comme ça je le dire nous
le corps réussi à passer au travers mais
il ya quand même des séquelles quand
même c'est quand même énorme puisqu'on
note juste le fait de nous les pianistes
perdant le prononcé de changer
d'instrument changer de mécanique à
chaque fois parce que les gens
s'imaginent de piano sud paille à 90,88
note c'est la même journée pas du tout
tous les palets piano sont réglés de
façon différente l'enfoncement n'est
jamais exactement le même jamais
parfaitement égale non plus ça veut dire
qu'à chaque fois qu'on essaie un piano
le pendant la nuit pour le concert du
lendemain
le corps est entre l esprit en train
d'enregistrer un qu'il faille est ici
était pas égal que c'est sûr
inconsciemment il ya une adaptation qui
se fait à chaque fois à l'instrument
donc c'est extrêmement précis et en même
temps assez pénible pour le corps il ya
des moments où on le sent on se dit
après ce concert là je vais te crever
parce qu'elle a vraiment cesse c'est pas
ça passe pas tout seul
mais vous avez déjà tenu la baguette en
tant que chef d'orchestre et la poste
qui s'ouvre à l'asm à ce que c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait me tenter
pas du tout parce que d'abord posté sm
c'est pas juste diriger une fois de
temps en temps comme ça c'est qu'il faut
être là certain nombre de semaines il
faut déjà avoir un répertoire énorme
comme tous les québécois j'ai évidemment
j'espérais que yannick nézet seguin
rives amourette recettes hors caisse
mais bon je suis sûr qu'ils vont faire
le choix le plus positif possible pour
montréal non j'ai pas du tout moi j'ai
fait ça comme ça un peu un peu comme
yannick le joue du piano
maintenant vous habite toujours en
allemagne en italie vous avez tous la
belgique et montréal quel est votre
prochain grand défi musical je retourne
à beethoven parce qu'avec le 250e
anniversaire l'année prochaine en 2020
donc je ne pouvais pas faire autrement
que de retourner en fait toutes les
sonates pour piano de beethoven donc
c'est ça mon prochain projet de
retourner parce que ça c'est vraiment
une chose qui change avec avec l'âge la
façon de voir un grand compositeur comme
beethoven seulement évolué d'une façon
assez important
où l'artiste
c